ja das ist ein wirklich krasses foto der
nasa ist es jetzt gelungen erstmalig im
bild festzuhalten wie sich ein schwarzes
loch beim fressen verhält und jetzt
haltet euch fest es wird richtig
menschlich ist macht ein nickerchen
holst und frist wieder ihr habt euch
dieses thema bei whatsapp gewünscht und
es ist wirklich fantastisch wie es
aussieht wenn ein schwarzes loch gleich
zweimal selbst und was der grund für
diese schlechte tischmanieren ist jetzt
ein klick zum science fiction herzlich
willkommen
wir berichten hier ja immer wieder mal
über schwarze löcher und viele von euch
wissen wohl was schwarze löcher am
besten können nämlich materie aufsaugen
wenn es keine materie rund um ihr
schwerefeld mehr gibt warten sie
geduldig ab wir sind wieder zuschlagen
können und materie verschlingen danach
stoßen sie einen strahl an partikeln aus
das war jetzt die mehr oder weniger
physikalische erklärung für das was
waren auf diesem bild der nasa jetzt
erstmalig sehen kann
ein schwarzes loch das obst und wie
konkret geht es dabei um die galaxie
sdss york bereit sind wir 50 plus 13 27
die etwa 800 millionen lichtjahre von
unserer erde entfernt ist sie befindet
sich im sternbild bärenhüter und in
ihrem zentrum ist ein super massereiches
schwarzes loch das millionenfach
schwerer als unsere sonne ist und ihm
ist wohl der pop art mit dem höchsten
passiert die beteiligte forscherin juli
comerford von der university of colorado
boulder selbst assoziiert das mit
menschlichem verhalten zitat schwarze
löcher sind ganz schön gefräßig aber sie
haben keine sehr gute tischmanieren das
besondere an diesem bild ist dass das
schwarze loch gleich zweimal auf stößt
das alles wurde vom satelliten chandra
aufgenommen und auf der 231 tagung der
american astronomical society im januar
vorgestellt konkret zu sehen sind zwei
gasblasen eine unterhalb und die andere
oberhalb des schwarzen lochs dazu juli
cover fort wir sehen wie das schwarze
loch frist ein nickerchen macht dann
wieder frisst und drückt genau wie
theoretisch vorhergesagt mann habe wohl
etwas glück gehabt dass man diese
galaxie genau zu diesem zeitpunkt
beobachtet habe indem diese eindeutigen
beweise zu sehen sind ihren
untersuchungen zufolge sind diese blasen
oder eben gas rückseite zu
unterschiedlichen zeiten aufgetreten aus
der geschwindigkeit der blasen schließt
das forschungsteam das sowohl in einem
abstand von etwa 100.000 jahren
ausgespuckt wurden kaum der rede wert
also im vergleich mit dem alter des
universums das auf 13,8 milliarden jahre
geschätzt wird für das schwarze loch so
etwas wie für uns der abstand vom
frühstück bis zum mittagessen oder warum
hat es gleich zweimal gefressen und
noch zweimal gerüst das forschungsteam
vermutet dass es zu einer kollision mit
einer nahen galaxie kamen so dass große
mengen an kosmischen gas als futter
dient es gab also zwei gänge total
ungewöhnlich sind solche tischmanieren
übrigens nicht auch das schwarze loch in
der milchstraße also in unserer galaxie
im zentrum hat wohl mindestens einmal in
den letzten paar millionen jahren gerade
macht es wohl ein verdauungs schläfchen
wenn ihr als erstes neues zum thema und
zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt
dann könnt euch hierbei whatsapp an dann
erfahrt ihr vor allen anderen vom
neuesten video garantiert ihr könnt dort
direkt in der redaktion vom krieg zum
mitmachen und themen vorschlagen oder
fragen zu videos stellen
der direkte draht zu mir einfach hier
draufklicken und natürlich nicht das abo
mit genau der glocken vergessen hier
geht es weiter mit dafür auch
draufklicken außerirdisches leben super
erde entdeckt ansonsten bis dann bleibt
dran